globally reported cases and deaths from
covet 19 are continuing to decline
with reported weekly deaths at their
lost since march 2020
but this trends while welcome don't tell
the full story
driven by omicron sub variants we are
seeing an increase in reported cases
in americas
and africa
the south african scientists who
identified omicron late last year have
now reported two more omicron sub
variants
bf4 and ba5
at the reason for a spike in cases in
south africa
it's too soon to know whether these new
set variants can cause more severe
diseases than other omicron subvariants
but early data suggests vaccination
remains protective against severe
disease and death
the best way to protect people remains
vaccination
alongside tried and tested public health
and social measures
this is another sign that the pandemic
is not done with us
and there are some clear takeaways
first
vaccinating at least 70 percent of the
population of every country
including 100 percent of the most at
risk groups remains the best way to save
lives
protect health systems and minimize
cases of long-covered
availability of vaccines has improved
significantly
but a combination of lack of political
commitment
operational capacity problems
financial constraints and hesitancy due
to misinformation and disinformation is
limiting demand for vaccines
we urge all countries to address this
bottlenecks to provide protection to
their populations
second
testing and sequencing remain absolutely
critical
the bf4 and bf5 sub variants were
identified because south africa is still
doing the vital genetic sequencing that
many other countries have stopped doing
in many countries we're essentially
blind to how the virus is mutating
we don't know what's coming next